And the correct answer is all the above and even more.
And the place that I found that was right here.
So I read down the documentation page a little bit and
I see that the kernel is one of the parameters.
And then I read this little statement that says it can be linear, poly, rbf,
sigmoid, precomputed, or a callable.
So, of course, all of these are correct answers.
The one that gave us the straight line in
the first example was the linear kernel.
And in general, that's what linear kernels are going to do.
They're going to draw a straight line.
The one that gave us this crazy squiggly decision boundary,
that was using an rbf kernel.